[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so I November I man mutters courage is
in Los Angeles for this year's la car
show he's very happy to be there first
because in Germany it would most likely
be gray and damp and also because there
are plenty of new models here for his
Christmas list understand need some 50
brand-new cars are debuting here 20 are
celebrating their world premieres but
there are also facelifted versions of
cars that have long been on the market
these are especially for car buyers
they've come to the show in droves it's
not limited to professionals there are
more models here ready for production
than at other car shows like the new
mini for example ganush mezzo climb them
mutters points out that the new
countryman is hardly mini he examines a
clever new feature he didn't quite
understand at first Struth fingers he
thought the cushion was meant to protect
the bumper while loading or unloading
the car but this didn't quite make sense
it's actually for sitting on if the
driver wants to take a rest in the open
air or take off dirty walking boots and
to change in the cleaner shoes to keep
the inside spotless physically clever
this feature thanks to the Lincoln
Navigator concept car you can forget
your house keys and still have a clean
outfit for the next day volkswagen is
aiming to become the world leader for
electric drive cars over the next 10
years they've just unveiled a new eGolf
d'ivoire got your good stock not
explains that the car has fifty percent
more range than before this amounts to
125 miles of driving before the battery
needs to be recharged so clients can
drive back and forth to work for several
days in a row this makes it far more
practical than before I'm not just hurts
what makes it different from the
conventional golf is the electric motor
sleeker body design and various details
the battery charger is under the fuel
cap so it doesn't take up space in the
trunk
in the creation mythology martes
explains that in Greek mythology Atlas
held up the heavens Volkswagen hopes
that its new atlas will prop up north
american sales matas thinks that this
full-size SUV was far too long reaching
the market he definitely wants it on his
Christmas list
Mazda's new compact SUV is somewhat
smaller it boasts the same elegant Kodo
design that the Japanese company first
introduced in its cx-5 a few years ago
the contours of the next generation
model are much more owned it's due out
in the first half of 2017
under the holga is Bernard Kaplan from
mazda explains to the familiar motor
lineup under the hood remains what's
changed and improved are the driver
assists and the electrical hatch he says
these are significant steps forward
nothing meant dengulata says it's a
shame the Mercedes scrapped the big open
vehicle segment that used to be a
fixture in their range but this new
Maybach s650 cabriolet could reverse the
decision he thinks it's a lovely car and
it's definitely going on his wish list
but he says he would offer different
rims for under that inside
Portia's new panamera executive is 15
centimeters longer than its previous
incarnation which already had plenty of
room but the panamera for a hybrid
executive is a whopping 5 meters 20
centimeters long of course the wheelbase
is also longer 3 meters tend to be
precise this makes the car more
comfortable for passengers and back
furthermore this hybrid car is very
efficient
[Music]
come on alive either from tickle me done
Portia's Oliver bluma says the range is
over 50 kilometers and the car bows 462
horsepower so performance is excellent
he says the vehicle is very
environmentally friendly and a lot of
fun too that's y agua Montes would also
like to put the Jaguar I pace concept on
his wish list but not for this Christmas
since it's not due for release till 2018
there's even a spaceship on show in Los
Angeles other this one hottest notices
it just as he's saying that his wish
list is already way too long and if he
were to get the spaceship for Christmas
where would he end up putting fan maybe
chef leave his wishes practical this
year in Los Angeles this turns on its
lightens posh Danish Dustin yet splits
the him
[Music]
then I found amake before when card
tester michelle austyn mcclure thought
of jaguar she thought of luxury sedans
with a discreet elegance and an
exclusive clientele then this one came
along then done come dare you it's loud
and wild but stylish the Jaguar f-type R
puts out extraordinary performance
encased in an extraordinary design
the stretched hood moves the passenger
compartment farther back curving into a
tightly rounded back with broad rear
fenders
the f-type R looks just as curvaceous
coming and going this all aluminum coupe
a is the sportiest snappiest production
model and jaguars history
[Music]
[Music]
the big cats 5-liter v8 engine puts out
405 kilowatts of power with 680 newton
meters of torque its top speed is
electronically capped at 300 km/h the
f-type R makes the 0 to 60 sprint and
4.2 seconds domin light on the student
up there since she doesn't head out to
the racetrack every day Michelle would
like to know if she can turn this
predator into a kitten but the
supercharging and direct injection don't
make it easy to tame Michelle wouldn't
say this ballistic missile has any sense
of English propriety it's loud it's
brutal and brawny and roars out the back
so nobody could fail to hear it for the
handsome 107,000 euro sticker price in
Germany the copay has to command respect
the eight-speed quick ship automatic
transmission makes for pickup on the
road and goose pimples on Michelle
[Music]
they get it stopped again just as fast
there's an optional carbon ceramic
matrix braking system
as it was see Michelle says all she has
to do is look at the brakes and they
catch the gas pedal responds almost as
fast barely tap it and f-type R leaps
forward no British understatement here
looking almost like a wardrobe
malfunction is the active rear spoiler
it pops up automatically at speeds
exceeding 110 km/h but doesn't pop back
down until the speed drops below 80
michelle is very pleased the Jaguar
f-type ours torque vectoring system
works with an electronically active
differential together they optimize
traction and stability rounding curves
and enhance the steering and agility and
Germany another six thousand euros gives
this jag all-wheel drive in little boy
once Michelle's turn the engine off the
interior almost makes her forget she's
sitting in a beast all the materials
feel so good and looks so nice but the
nicest part of all is raising and
lowering the vents it almost seems
choreographed all the f-type interiors
are geared to the driver all the
controls are within easy reach the
comfort and joy are the performance
sport seats offering inflatable side
bolstering for extra support of the
upper body during high-speed cornering
the premium leather adds a sensual touch
[Music]
Michelle was still trying to tame her
Jaguar she'd like to be able to take it
shopping I bring home cases of mineral
water she's amazed that she could
actually fit two inside with more space
in front so this is a car she can use as
a deposit Remagen scoot
about us highlight for books but the
real highlight is upfront under the hood
zorgons Whitman she doesn't think she'd
ever be able to tame the Jaguar f-type
are completely at heart it will always
be a wild beasts with brute force there
may be no way to hide it but nobody's
likely to steal it either this Jaguar is
heard as much a scene the sound will
turn heads on every side right from the
moment the engine lets out its first
mighty roar
[Music]
japanese carmaker suzuki built its
reputation on the strength of its
compact cars one of the makes best
sellers is the Swift popular since 1983
the model got its most recent facelift
in 2013 though externally similar and
has little in common with the 2005
version when it comes to technology the
cottage makar chester and elite
zimmerman wants to know whether the
suzuki swift is a long-term success or
in the face of competition may be losing
some of its steam when it comes to
engine options on the Swift there aren't
that many apart from the sports version
every Swift that rolls off the assembly
line is equipped with a 1.2 liter engine
an eco plus package that cuts co2
emissions 299 g/km is optional it simply
drops power output by a barely
noticeable three kilowatts the top speed
remains unchanged at 165 km/h the
Swift's motor doesn't quite cut the
mustard for Andre its performance is all
right but from a purely subjective
standpoint it kicks in too late you need
high revs it's not much fun to drive
fast in the Swift offerings for flats
moving
but super minis are designed to be
practical City cars Suzuki itself calls
the Swift a city-run about with
something more at 3 meters 85 in length
and eases into tight parking spaces that
turning radius is just 10.4 meters if
you opt for a swift without the eco plus
package which lowers clearance by 10
millimeters and cuts the turning radius
even further to an impressive 9.6 meters
when an income Andre says the steering
is a bit on the stiff side but it also
doesn't give a lot of feedback one thing
that bothered him a bit at least
initially is that the clutch feels soft
but that's not necessarily a drawback he
does like the smooth shifting the gears
slip up and down almost effortlessly he
appreciates that very much doesn't smoke
nice easy as a good the Swift has a
distinctive look our test car with the
comfort equipment line features aluminum
rims LED daytime running and fog lights
integrated in the bumper as well as a
light sensor
[Music]
the interior is a bit bland
[Music]
I'm gonna pick up the luggage
compartment offers about 70 liters less
space than competing models Andre says
and the sill height seems to be dictated
by a biblical measure of one cubit
rather a lot but surely less means more
space for the rear seat the big door
makes it easy to get in on Dre finds but
to be honest he says he expected more
from the rear seat given that the trunk
is so small it's okay for short hops
because your knees push against the seat
here but you wouldn't want to sit here
long and the Headroom is surprisingly
low priceless Swift is priced
competitively but overall you get more
for your money with other brands still
the Swift has one big sales edge it's a
compact car available in four-wheel
drive which is not something you find
off that's the wifey stepfathers
starting at under sixteen thousand euros
in Germany the four-wheel-drive Swift
doesn't even cost more than the normal
model equipped with a comfort line and
even if the four-wheel drive only comes
in the pared-down Club trim without the
light sensor tinted rear window and
aluminum rims all in all it's a good buy
especially for drivers in suburban or
more rural areas
[Music]
manchmal uber car chester vinyl Dyson
hofer recalls that some 40 years ago the
then IBM CEO Thomas J Watson estimated
the world market for personal computers
at only five units a prime example of
how reality can shatter all expectations
in the 1980s and 90s hardly anyone had
any idea what an SUV was by 2013 nearly
a quarter million had been sold and
another hundred thousand by 2015 and the
market is still growing so it's no
surprise that say odd is now offering an
SUV it's called the Atika the Sienna
teka premiered in the geneva motor show
in march 2016 demand for the model was
so high that say ott had to stop taking
orders in September by then delivery
times had reached at least 10 months and
there was a reason the sporty looking
Spanish SUV is available with a range of
fuel-efficient engines the smallest of
the engines is a one liter TSI with just
three cylinders the kind normally found
only in compacts more powerful is the
2-liter TDI with over 140 kilowatts of
output
[Music]
the thick brunette Bauer CEO see how
Germany notes that compact SUVs overall
market share grew by sixty-five percent
in five years while sea oats jumped
eighty-eight percent those two facts
combined makes yachts SUV predestined
for growth drivers want to sit higher in
a practical vehicle all good news for
the segment one component is like
mentally our test car is a 1.4 liter
Ecotec I with four-wheel drive the 110
kilowatt engine accelerates from 0 to
100 km/h in 9 seconds maximum speed is
around 192 kilometers an hour with a top
equipment line excellence the attacker
runs 29 thousand euros in Germany
Natalie's come naturally Rhino says you
could go off-road on light to medium
rough terrain but normally no one does
drivers on a sporty safe car the
company's own drivers assists include
the radar assistant cruise control it
can bring the car to a full stop and
keep going and in stop-and-go traffic
it'll automatically accelerate
substandard gossip the attacker is
compact and light our test car weighs in
at 14 hundred and 60 kilograms omitting
four-wheel drive lightens it by ninety
six kilos that makes the attackers
sporty and fun to drive even with its
fuel efficient engines and looks the
part to the excellence version comes
with full LED headlights with dynamic
range adjustment as well as tail lights
with LED technology
[Music]
top spec cars come equipped with ciothes
media system plus featuring an 8-inch
touchscreen and eight speakers the star
button pulses like a heartbeat when the
driver nears the car with the key the
drive mode button is within easy reach
leather seats are available at a
surcharge musin vasily timati here we
see the full range of upgrades available
on the Atika from skid plates in front
and back in an aluminum finish to
special rims and exterior mirror caps
and silver a roof rack and running board
these can all be fitted after purchase
see that's a lot more accommodating in
that area than other brands see got
stresses that the Atika doesn't just
look like an SUV it really can be used
off-road at the same time it rides like
a sports car efficient tensions and
appealing design put the Atika and the
fast lane to success
the NSU spider debuted at the 1963
frankfurt motor show and it caused
something of a commotion msu announced
it would start production within a year
with a plan three to five thousand units
annually loving attention to detail made
it an instant classic the spider listed
at an impressive 8,500 Deutsche marks or
some 4,200 euros but once the initial
uproar had died down the two-seater
convertible was widely ignored by the
German market after months of delay in
September 1964 NSU raffled off the first
one off the assembly line to an employee
the fuel tank and radiator were mounted
in front the engine and back that gave
the engineers an optimal weight
distribution the ancient small size
allowed for a second trunk space a
unique feature at the time humming
underneath almost like a turbine was the
50 horsepower Wankel engine I mean boner
was assigned to work on the rotary
engine and nsu's R&D division he has
fond memories of the project and the
advantages of the rotary concept in the
mid-1950s NSU had already designed its
kkm engine with a static housing based
on Felix Wonka's original dkm rotary
engine design and a spinning housing but
the engine that was to carry the Wankel
name perform noticeably better the one
thing with toys he explains that the
Wankel engines mass is balanced a great
advantage over the reciprocating piston
engine which is harder to balance the
vibration is always carried over to the
vehicle and a rotary engine by contrast
there's hardly any vibration inside the
car the car just takes off with the
engine purring like an electric motor
another benefit was the power density or
the performance potential the
reciprocating piston engines of the time
were somewhat weaker so the rotary
engine offered some advantages there too
bitsy fission lies don't was real oh and
the swamp so the argument a demon heart
and NSU had high hopes for the Wankel
engine
arman bouta remembers it well the
designer suggested building a roadster
with it because the engine was so small
it could be rear mounted so the car
would have trunk space in front and room
for another storage space over the
engine and back that's the design spider
went ahead with it was the first car
that went into series production with a
Wankel engine fill in fall psychic Dale
that partition ceiling a gun miss the
engine was extremely high revving and
compared to other small engines very
smooth revolutions about 6000 per minute
were no problem from the mechanical
standpoint but over longer periods the
cooling system couldn't keep up the
spider could run from 0 to 100 km/h and
14 and a half seconds unlike the NSU ro
80 the spider had a 500cc single rotor
Wankel engine with fuel consumption
rated at 10 liters per hundred
kilometers it all seemed so promising
NSU set out to write automotive history
but it just didn't work the apex seals
on the combustion chambers kept wearing
out for some time NSU was very obliging
when it came to fixing the many problems
but the cars image suffered the original
goal of 5,000 spiders per year soon
proved utopian the market never
materialized and the first year of
production NSU sold only 151 units by
comparison 1965 was a good year with 923
sales by the time production was halted
in 1967 only 2375 spiders had been sold
today it's a rarity and the fact that
it's the world's first series produce
car with a Wankel engine makes the
spider a highly sought-after collector's
item a good condition spider will put a
serious dent in your bank account
restoring a spider can easily exceed the
cost of a new car tracking down parts is
like a treasure hunt with no guarantee
you'll ever find what you're looking for
only about 450 spiders still exist today
you
[Music]
[Music]